يوتيوب يوتيوب
الا ان يحمل لشبه الجزيره الكوريه مزيدا
من السيناريوهات القاتمه فها هو رجل بيونج
جانجل قوي كيم جونغ اون يعلن بلا تحفظ
استراتيجيه بلاده الدفاعيه لعام 2023
استراتيجيه تقوم على تعزيز القوه العسكريه
بشكل عام لكنها تستند بالاساس الى الردع
النووي ردا على ما سماها السياسات
العدائيه المتبعه من قبل الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه
طال بكين بزياده هائله في الترسانه
النوويه بما فيها الرؤوس التكتيكيه
والصواريخ البالستيه العابره للقارات كما
دعا الى تطوير خطط لاطلاق قمر صناعي
للتجسس الى الفضاء في اسرع وقت ممكن
الجنوبيه جاء سريعا بالعقاد اجتماع طارق
ضم القاده السياسيين والعسكريين ولاحقا
حذر وزير الدفاع في صول من ان بلاده سترد
بقوه دون تردد على اي استفزاز مباشر من
الشطر الشمالي وان الجيش سيطور قدراته
لردع تلك المخاطر
وبلغت تهديدات ذروتها باعلان الوزير
الكوري الجنوبي ان اي استخدام لسلاح
النووي من بيونغيانج سيعني حتما نهايه
نظامي كيم جونغ اون
جاءت هذه التطورات على وضع ضجيج التجاري
الصاروخيه المستمره فبعد اطلاقها ثلاثه
صواريخ يوم السبت اطلقت كوريا الشماليه
ليله السبت الاحد صاروخا بالسيا اخر
باتجاه بحر اليابان المعروف ايضا باسم
البحر الشرقي الشماليه
فقد بيونغيانغ هذا العام نحو 70 صاروخا
ينظر اليها على انها رسائل غضب من
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه في المنطقه
من جانب الولايات المتحده وحلفتيها كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان والتوتر قد يبلغ ذروته
في العام الجديد حيث لم يترك الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي اي مجال تقريبا للعوده الى
محادثات نزع السلاح المتعثر منذ زمن طويل
مع الشطر الجنوبي بل ثمه من المراقبين من
راى في هذا التصعيد انذارا باحتمال ان
تصبح شبه الجزيره الكوريه اوكرانيا ثانيه
اذا ما ادرت الازمه بشكل سيء
[موسيقى]